today the Matt wall show the
over-educated credentialed elite class
has made it clear that most of us are
not qualified to speak or form our own
opinions and yet somehow we are
qualified to pay their student loans
we'll discuss also I have the honor of
being a part of a bill signing event in
Mississippi Banning gender transitions
for minors I'll talk about that and Lori
Lightfoot the first black gay female
mayor of Chicago is also now the first
Chicago mayor in decades to lose
re-election she lost because she's
historically incompetent but she blames
you'll never guess racism and a school
shooting Survivor competes on American
Idol but Katy Perry uses his trauma as a
platform for pushing gun control we'll
talk about all that and more today on
Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
you worked hard for what you have uh who
do you trust to handle any and all of
your financial obligations if you can
according to a recent poll 62 of
Americans who think about their own
death a lot of the time still don't have
a will that's kind of like being afraid
of drowning but refusing to wear a life
jacket or learn how to swim creating a
will is one of the most important things
you can do to ensure your belongings and
your loved ones are taken care of after
you pass away my partners at Epic will
can help you get set up with a will
today and they can do it for just 119
and in as little as five minutes epic
will can help you create your last will
and testament your living will even
Health Care power of attorney go to
epicwell.com Walsh to get my discount
code and save an extra 10 on your
complete wheel package with epic wheels
easy to use template all you have to do
is fill in the blanks go to epicwell.com
Welsh to save 10 on Epic Will's complete
will package that's epicwill.com slash
Welsh while it won't be easy to pick
just one inscription to put on the
tombstone of modern culture but if we
have only one that we can pick then I
think we might consider the phrase trust
the experts or perhaps because it's on
our Tombstone we should phrase it in the
past tense you know like here lies 21st
century America they trusted the experts
now these days of course we all carry
around in our pockets more information
than we could hope to consume in a
billion lifetimes and with all this
information comes countless informers
billions of people all talking to each
other passing information along back and
forth every technological advancement
has its downsides of course and there's
there's no question that the internet
has plenty of those we talk about them
all the time but for the elites and for
the institutions they run the downside
is that all of this informational
accessibility all of this communicating
that normal people are able to do with
each other
marginalizes them the elites they feel
themselves getting cut out of the
picture they believe that uh they should
be in charge of what people are told and
not told of what information is shared
and not shared of what ideas are spread
and not spread ultimately they wish to
be in charge of what people know or
think they know and therefore what they
believe about the world and about
themselves
and that's why they've redoubled their
efforts in recent years to combat what
they call misinformation which is their
euphemism for any information that they
for whatever reason don't want people
exposed to
trust the experts they declare which is
another way of saying don't trust your
own intuition your own common sense or
your own two eyes your own brain your
own ability to read information and
process it trust us instead
these uh self-described experts
have then used their self-appointed
expert status to lead us into one
Calamity after another the experts told
us to lock ourselves in our homes during
covid to wear masks to take the vaccine
the experts tell us to
stop having children to start eating
bugs to stop driving cars to stop
enjoying the same modern technology that
they continue to enjoy because it's
destroying the planet when we do it but
not when they do it the expert tells us
to put our kids on chemical castration
drugs the experts tell us that men can
give birth to babies that there are 900
genders the experts tell us that every
facet of The Human Condition is actually
a mental illness the expert tells tells
us that the nuclear family is an
outmoded institution the experts tell us
that we have no souls that there is no
God that there is no underlying purpose
or or you know meaning to existence
the experts wave their resumes around
flash their degrees of fixed letters to
the beginnings and ends of their names
and demand that we show unthinking
deference to those credentials when we
ask why we should they simply point back
to the credential as if the credential
uh is as if the credibility conferred by
the credential is self-evident but it
isn't
now never mind that the credentialed
class has been wrong
about basically everything for years now
and not merely wrong I mean they're
pushing the most wrong most baseless
most destructive and outright insane
ideas
that the human mind has ever conceived
of
they profess a vision of the world that
is entirely divorced from reality and
the farther their Vision drifts from
reality
the more aggressive they must be in
their efforts to discredit and shout
down and censor and silence information
that contradicts that vision
the experts are very often wrong and
their wrongness has made them vulnerable
and their vulnerability has made them
afraid
and their fear has made them tyrannical
now of course I happen to be a Target
personally of this credentialed elitism
very often because I have a large
platform I take positions that
contradict the Elite's preferred
narrative and I do all this without even
having so much as a college degree to my
name I graduated high school by the skin
of my teeth I went to Community College
for like a semester and then dropped out
and that's the extent of my academic
resume
this infuriates them I mean in anyone
anyone in this category that you don't
have they didn't even go to college and
you would dare to have opinions and
ideas and to say them out loud it
infuriates them
which is why their Primary Response to
me and so many others their first and
usually only rebuttal is to point out
that I have no degrees or certificates
framed and hanging on the walls in my
office while they have many
the only frame certificate that I have
in my office at the at Daily wire
headquarters is a printout of the top
LGBT books on Amazon when Johnny The
Walrus was number one in that category
that is the only credential that I ever
boast about and the only one I have or
need
well there was a fresh round of these
sorts of attacks after uh my testimony
at a Tennessee house hearing a few weeks
ago where as we saw a Democrat lawmaker
made sure to point to my lack of
academic credentials as evidence that
I'm not qualified to make provocative
statements like women don't have penises
and you shouldn't castrate a child
uh ever since that moment
many on the left have been jumping yet
again on this bandwagon taking turns
lobbing pot shots at the high school
graduate who dared to form an opinion
that they did not sanction ahead of time
this led to a what is now a viral tweet
from um someone who goes by Dr Ian
Copeland PhD which is how he refers to
himself in his Twitter handle well
actually was he took the doctor off
because he was getting bullied everyone
was making fun of him for it and so he
took that off but he still has Ian
Copeland PhD
um he took a screenshot of this exchange
at the hearing not not didn't post the
video just a screenshot of the video
because I want people to see the video
screenshot and posted this caption
alongside it
side note why do people listen to Matt
Walsh about well anything he's a high
school graduate talking about biology
sex policy and vaccines he literally
yields no value on any of these topics
I would like to respond to that but then
again I may not be academically
qualified enough to answer direct
attacks made against me
I would need to spend three years at an
Ivy League graduate school studying the
silence the science of rebuttals first I
would need to take a class with a name
like um the art of the clap back race
and gender in the age of the Twitter
feud or whatever
but even without this kind of
accreditation I I still feel the need to
make a few points to these over
credentialed snobs
first if you want to run with the idea
that high school graduates should not be
taken seriously when they express their
views on any topic that we aren't even
qualified to make statements about basic
biological realities
then you're free to do so you could say
that but please don't insult our
intelligence however limited you might
think it is
by turning around in the next breath and
pretending to be a champion of the poor
and the working class
I mean these are the people who fix
our cars and our plumbing and maintain
all the buildings and the bridges
provide you with all the food you eat
they run and staff every store you shop
in you'd be utterly helpless without
them and yet to you
they shouldn't be taken seriously
they can do all these things for you but
they but anything they say should not be
taken seriously their their view of the
world is less than worthless
you've waved your magic wand and
discredited all of them at once
which of course is the whole point you
want the masses to come crawling to you
on hands and knees heads bowed in
submission asking for your blessing
before they formulate any thoughts of
Their Own
again you're free to hold this
perspective but please don't pretend to
be anything but a snide elitist prick
peering down on the common man with
contempt because that's what you are of
course you know not everyone who has no
college degree is poor Blue Collar nor
do we all know how to fix your cars or
your plumbing I certainly don't and in
my case I used to be poor I'm not
anymore these days I earn a Better
Living than lots of the people who have
all those fancy letters next to their
names
and that really really makes them angry
because they followed the system
I went around it and ended up ahead of
them
and that infuriates them and I'm glad it
does
but most of their anger is a defense
mechanism they hide behind their
credentials because they know that their
ideas cannot stand on their own they
have to prop them up with the pieces of
paper that they plunge themselves into
six-figure debt to obtain
I've already asked this question to a
doctor PhD Ian and now I'll ask it again
to the entire credential because I mean
I've been asking it can't get an answer
taking that hearing for example is that
that hearing to testify against the
mutilation and castration of children
can you explain why I'm wrong in my
views on that subject if I'm nothing but
a drooling low IQ dunce walking around
and like grass stained overalls with no
shoes and five missing teeth you know
like we high school graduates always do
but it should be very easy to defeat
whatever arguments
we say in fact you shouldn't need to
point out the lack of schooling you
should be able to demonstrate my
deficiencies by masterfully debunking me
Point by point you should be able to use
your years of academic training to
explain and defend your point of view
and provide persuasive evidence that
yours is right and mine is wrong but you
don't do that you don't even try
you shrink away from any opportunity to
actually demonstrate why your ideas are
correct because you can't demonstrate it
and you know you can't
your degrees are supposed to act as a
ring of protection a force field around
your ideas exempting them from scrutiny
but many of us have noticed that the
force field is imaginary and so we're
walking right through it and right up to
you
and demanding that you justify your
unearned sense of importance
we're just not respecting the academic
hierarchy because it's done everything
in its power to lose our respect
so now we're flipping it on its head and
we're tossing it aside
and that scares the credential people
and it should
now one final point there have been
protests in DC this week
as the Supreme Court considers whether
to strike down Biden's unconstitutional
quote-unquote student loan forgiveness
plan
um the protesters insist that uh not
only should the plan be kept in place
but that it should go further than it
already does
you know all they want all student debt
to be erased
and half of that debt we should remember
is held by people with graduate degrees
so these are
you know what you've got is in large
part
people with graduate degrees and all
those fancy letters
that are demanding that working-class
people pay their debts for them
one of those protesters was a was a
teachers union president Randy
Weingarten who was there and uh and she
spoke and and we can add public speaking
to the list of skills that this person
doesn't have listen
Ed that's small businesses were hurting
and we helped them and it didn't go to
the Supreme Court to challenge it fake
businesses were hurting and we helped
them and it didn't go to the Supreme
Court to challenge it all of a sudden
what is about our students
they challenge it the corporations
challenge it the student loan lenders
challenge that that is not right that is
not fair and that is what we are
fighting as well when we say cancel soon
and dead
I mean it's an interesting strategy
because you hear that you listen to this
person speak and you're tempted to say
okay I'll I'll give you whatever you
want just stop talking please God
of course Wine Garden is a ranking
member of the system that created the
student debt crisis in the first place
and now she wants a bailout precisely so
that they can continue continue doing
everything they did to cause the problem
but I also can't help but notice staying
on the topic here the connection between
the trust the experts credentialism
and the push for student loan
forgiveness
because the very people who waive their
degrees around as evidence of their
superiority
now want us to pay for those degrees
okay they tell us that we are not
qualified to speak to form opinions to
debate or discuss
and yet we are qualified apparently to
carry the financial burden of their own
life choices
we're qualified for that
they talk down to us and they have the
gumption the gall to do it with their
hands in our pockets
now this is far from the only reason to
say no to this kind of upper class
welfare scheme which is what quote
unquote student loan forgiveness is and
that really is all the reason you need
to say no to it it is upper class
welfare
but this is this is if it's not if it's
uh not the only reason it's one of them
you cannot treat us like a children and
expect us to be your sugar daddy at the
same time
if anything it should go the other way
if you want your loan forgiven
if you wanna and you you're saying that
we should be the ones to forgive it
we're the ones paying for it
well you should have to give up first of
all all of your precious titles and
degrees
so what happens if you don't pay for
your car your house you lose it
to begin with there should be a
repossession
you should have to Forfeit those letters
next to your name
in fact you should have to give your
titles to us the people paying the bill
then at least it'd be a swap instead of
a straightforward theft
if I'm paying for your PhD I should get
it it belongs to me
I bought it not you look at me I'm the
PHD now that's what it should be
that's a satisfying thought in some ways
but uh ultimately
uh I don't think I would accept that
deal that's a better deal than anything
they've proposed
because I don't want anyone's useless
credential
that's their humiliation to bear
and a debt that came with it is their
problem to solve I mean you guys are so
much smarter than us right
well then then figure it out geniuses
the fact is that your degrees do not
confer the kind of qualifications that
you imagine but they do at least qualify
you to pay for them okay that's one
qualification that you do have
and that is one credential
the credential of debt holder DH put
those letters next to your name
that I absolutely will respect
now let's get to our five headlines
foreign
[Music]
economic forecasts that lie ahead you
might be looking for ways to cut back on
spending I know most of us are well Pure
Talk saves the average family over 900 a
year when they switch from Verizon at T
or T-Mobile get unlimited talk text and
plenty of data for just thirty dollars a
month Pure Talk is so sure that you're
going to love their service they're
backing it up with a 100 money back
guarantee stop paying a fortune to
Verizon ATT or T-Mobile cut your bill in
half with pure talk their us-based
customer service team makes the switch
really easy switch over to Pure Talk in
as little as 10 minutes while keeping
your phone and your phone number uh your
first month is guaranteed risk-free but
you got to go to puretalk.com enter
promo code Walsh to save 50 off on your
first month I know I use Pure Talk you
should use it too that's puretalk.com
promo code Welsh Pure Talk is simply
smarter Wireless restrictions applies
Seaside for details yesterday I was
honored to attend the bill signing in
Mississippi of a law Banning the medical
transition of children in that state
it's the Nationwide movement as I've
been saying this is not just in
Tennessee it's not just in one say it's
one state after another and the governor
of Mississippi Governor Reeves was nice
enough to invite me to be a part of the
event and it was great I said a few
words of the signing and hung around for
the press conference where um we're a
field in some of the questions now
I will admit I will admit uh just to be
entirely transparent that I was a little
bit disappointed that the leftist
journalists in the room completely
folded just folded like a like a you
know like a lawn furniture and didn't
try to challenge me at all I mean even
given the opportunity with me standing
right there and the camera's rolling
didn't try to challenge that of course
wasn't the point of the event the point
is that there's very important bill was
signed and now children are protected in
uh in Mississippi
but kind of hoping for the cherry on top
where the media would try to come after
me and they and they didn't
although it's been funny after the fact
to
see how these people processed this and
the fact that I was there for example
here's a guy named uh Kobe Vance they
them trans flag and bio uh journalists
for Mississippi Public Broadcasting
and he was there and he did ask a
question before I get to that let's hear
he kept a running thread of everything
was going on this is what he said uh he
starts with I'm in the governor's office
today at Tate Reeves prepares to stay
prepares to sign HB 1125 into law it
will ban gender affirming health care
for Trans youth Reeves is going on about
side effects of gender transition drugs
which are well documented and known
about the trans Community he says
conservatives are under attack from the
left for trying to question trans rights
by being called transphobic
I believe transphobic public figure Matt
Walsh is here in the room although this
is just a guess they look very similar
and have otherwise never seen them in
person
then he says confirmed it is Walsh
Governor Reeves introduced him during
the press conference to speak
I asked a very specific question about
how the state will respond to a rise in
suicide for Trans youth Reeves did
answer my question pointing back to his
policy on life says part of the answer
should be Mental Health Services Walsh
deflected the question
Walsh points to lack of scientific data
on trans Youth and that hormone therapy
can't improve mental health that wasn't
my question I asked how losing their
body positivity could increase suicide
rates
uh Reeves says that he personally
opposes the idea of adults transitioning
their gender but does not want to
infringe on adults rights to make the
medical decisions says he draws the line
at youth
for most of the questions about HP 1125
Reeves has deferred to Walsh that's not
true to expound on whatever answer he
gives Walsh's extensive experience
debating trans issues on his show so I
just thought this was interesting
because
I remember this this guy uh asking this
question about suicide and I answered it
he says I deflected of course he's lying
about that I answered the question about
suicide extensively and from several
different angles
uh in fact we have a here's just part of
my answer to that question this is the
last minute or so of the answer that I
provided
um but enough to see that there's
nothing like a deflection going on here
here it is
not only does it Define common sense but
I find it I find a frankly grotesque
that the way to stop a child from
tragically hurting themselves is to
affirm their belief
that there's something wrong with their
body that they were born in the wrong
body that they're the wrong person no
the way to help anyone who's in despair
in that way especially a child is to is
to help them towards actual
self-acceptance who you really are so if
you're a biological male and you're a
boy and you're 15 years old and you feel
like you're a girl the message should be
uh no you're a boy and that's a
wonderful thing to be who you are and
and we will help you to accept that
because it's wonderful to be who you are
this is who you are that should be our
message instead the message they get
from the medical community is well okay
if you if you feel like you're born the
wrong body then you were
and we'll start chopping pieces of you
off
until the bad thoughts go away and I
just find that to be
utterly horrific and uh and
insane on its face
now I also pointed out that before that
that statistically suicidality is the
highest after transition I pointed out
that the claims that transition
decreases suicide are baseless and must
be baseless because there couldn't
possibly be enough data to support it
given that these are experimental
treatments that we just recently started
giving to kids at a large scale so
pointed out to all points all that and
um
along with what you just heard there
that counts as a deflection of the
question somehow
but Kobe this journalist he didn't
challenge me at all in fact I gave this
answer and kind of bowed his head
submissively and and then he but then he
proceeded to to tweet about it instead
not a big surprise
um
in fact this is what I've of course
totally come to expect
but it but every time it happens that
I'm in the room with these people
claim that I'm uh unqualified bigot and
have nothing of value to say and
everything that I'm saying is wrong
okay
you got a chance to prove it
you know that now is the time
and they they never do they rarely even
try
and every time that happened every time
that happens and they Dodge like that
um yeah it's a it's it's a little
annoying because I'm deprived of the fun
moment to you know argue with them but
more importantly it's actually it's
actually
infuriating because it yet again proves
that these people know at some level
that what they're claiming isn't true
and doesn't stand up to scrutiny
they know that they they know they can't
defend it
they know that they're they are they
have staked out a position that they
can't actually defend which is why they
will decline almost every opportunity to
defend it because they can't
and that's what makes it infuriating is
that when you realize that all these
things that are happening this madness
that's being pushed on society it's not
even being pushed by people who are
confused or deluded or who uh have the
best intentions is this is not a road to
hell is paved with good intentions sort
of situation I mean the Roadhouse also
pay for bad intentions
and these people have bad intentions
um
it's not it's not that they are wrong
it's that they're evil
I guess is the way to put it
all right
Deli wire has a support Chicago Democrat
mayor Lori Lightfoot lost her reelection
race Tuesday after her first term was
plagued by crime the inability to
recover from the pandemic and Petty
fighting with officials homicide rates
under lightfoot's tenure have
skyrocketed to generational highs while
robberies muggings carjackings other
property crimes have all seen a
significant increase the two candidates
that advanced the runoff race are former
school school CEO paulus who received
the most votes at 35 percent with nearly
90 of the votes in the other candidates
Cook County Commissioner Brandon Johnson
who garnered 20 of the vote Lightfoot
only earned 16 percent of the vote the
associate press called the race for
vallis and Johnson vallis has tried to
portray himself as tougher on crime and
uh and uh more moderate than Lightfoot
while Johnson is unabashedly far left
so it goes to runoff but Lori Lightfoot
is not going to be the mayor so she's
lost which is great news
great news in a lot of ways Lori
Lightfoot is making history yet again
she was the first black gay female mayor
of Chicago
and also the first mayor in Chicago in
decades to lose re-election so she is
breaking glass ceilings everywhere she
goes
she also has been easily among the worst
mayors of a major American city ever I
mean ever to be elected and that is uh
that's not hyperbole
when you look at the the
disaster that she has left in her wake
it is it is almost unrivaled by any
other mayor in American history of a
major American city
so she's proven that a gay black female
mayor can truly achieve things that
nobody else could possibly achieve like
a 100 increase in violent crime in a
couple of years I that is uh
it would be very difficult to achieve
that even if you were trying to and she
was able to do that
of course Lightfoot saw the writing on
the wall and she knew that she was about
to lose this race and humiliating
fashion
so she set up her excuse ahead of time
and you'll never guess what the excuse
is
okay actually you will guess because she
blames sexism and racism obviously what
else is she going to do this was the
daily wire report from earlier in the
day yesterday before the election
results came in but Lori Lightfoot was
was setting the stage
Chicago mayor Lori Lightfoot is facing
an uphill battle in her bid for
re-election while she primarily blames
racism for her plight she also blames
Time magazine for failing to elevate her
the way they did her predecessor
while Lightfoot conceded to politico's
Jonathan Martin that she had certainly
made some mistakes during her time as
mayor she claimed that the real issue
was the fact that people were quicker to
pass judgment on a black woman
quote of course you can't have lived
through what we live through and say I
did everything perfect we made mistakes
she said pivoting to bring former mayor
Rahm emanuel's Time Magazine spread into
the conversation I remember Rahm Emanuel
appearing on the cover of Time Magazine
the headline was basically like tough
guy for Chicago no woman or woman of
color is ever going to get that headline
Lightfoot the city's black first black
female lesbian mayor made a similar
complaint during another interview with
the New Yorker she said I'm a black
woman and let's not forget some folks
frankly don't support us in leadership
roles
then an interview last year she was uh
at the singing a similar tune she was
asked this question this was the
question
in recent months there have been
questions raised about your temperament
and your reaction to criticism the
Chicago Tribune editorial used the term
irascible
how much of this do you think have has
to do with the fact that you're a woman
and specifically a black woman her
response 99 of it look at my
predecessors do people say that that
rich Daley held T sessions with people
that he didn't disagree on
Rahm Emanuel was was a polite guy who
was on a uniter no woman and women and
people of color are always held to a
different standard I understand that
I've known that my whole life
and she's right obviously I mean she is
right
um if you are
uh
in particular a leftist
and then you belong to one of these
preferred identity groups
absolutely you're held to a different
standard a lower one
I mean a much lower standard that's what
makes these claims so ridiculous because
they they are as always the opposite of
what's actually true Lightfoot says oh
can you imagine can you imagine a
magazine cover celebrating a black woman
uh yes
because that's like every magazine
covered oh do you mean every magazine
cover for the past 10 years just about
I mean a magazine cover celebrating a
white man that's what's rare these days
I'm actually I'm surprised that Time
Magazine did that for Ronald Manuel
he's Democrat so you know he he makes it
through based on that
but the rare thing is to see a white
male being celebrated by the media at
all
um
to see a black woman or someone who
belongs to one of these groups being
celebrated that's that's that's every
day I mean that is literally every day
that's that that talk about 99 that's 99
of what the media in Hollywood turns out
but also note this and this goes this
goes to a point that I made at the end
of the show yesterday
um one of the guys who beat her Brandon
Johnson
is black okay he's a black guy
and not only that but he she was she was
uh defeated by a black man
at the hands of Voters who were also uh
a large percentage of them black this is
Chicago we're talking about
so a lot of black voters voted for a
black person instead of Lori Lightfoot
and she blames racism
well remember what I said yesterday
personal complaints
are disguised as group complaints that's
the game here
okay like every time you hear a leftist
Who belongs to one of these supposedly
marginalized groups complaining about
um about the the treatment of the group
in almost every case
this person is really complaining about
how they personally are being treated or
how they perceive their own treatment
that's what's actually happening
so when you hear how could you do this
to us what it really means every time is
how could you do this to me
which is why Lori Lightfoot is not going
to take any solace in the fact you know
that uh that she was she that another
quote-unquote person of color defeated
her
and if that person is elected
that's not going to stop her from
claiming discrimination
because she doesn't care whether black
people or a black person becomes mayor
she doesn't care about that she wants
herself to be mayor
there is one specific black individual
that Lori Lightfoot is concerned about
and it's her it's not anyone else
next we had Biden gave a speech
yesterday it gave rise to another clip
of Biden mumbling incoherently
um at least that's what people are
saying on social media this clip is
being passed around is another Biden
word salad uh let's listen to it
[Applause]
by the way
you docs are good if there's any angels
in heaven they're all nurses male and
female
you know why you guys let us you guys
make us allow us to live
nurses make you one of this
you know I don't do this often I got to
defend Biden on this one it did take I
had to listen to it three or four times
but but once you get
it's like an optical illusion type of
thing and once you you don't see it at
first at first glance but once you see
it it becomes obvious and so what he's
he said is you docs are good but if
there's any angels in heaven they're all
nurses male and female you know why you
guys allow us to live the nurses make us
want to live
now say what you want about that
sentiment the sentiment itself doesn't
make a whole lot of sense but that is
that's what he said so
it it you know
it's it is to say that that was
indecipherable word salad
is not fair it was decipherable word
salad it can be decided takes a little
bit of time but you can't decipher it I
thought that this clip from the same
speech
um I thought that this clip was more
much more disturbing even though you can
understand the words that are coming out
of his mouth
um you kind of wish that you hadn't
based on what he says listen
and I had a nurse named Pearl Nelson
military
she'd come in and do things that I don't
think can learn the medical school
Nursery School
she'd whisper in my ear I didn't
couldn't understand him she whispered
she'd leaned down
it actually breathed on me to make sure
that I was there was a connection to
human connection
she even went home and brought back her
pillow from her own bed because he
didn't knew the one who had that wasn't
comfortable
but I'm not joking
I was like what
I could understand I could basically
understand the story that he was telling
but the question is uh why he was
telling that
and then there it erases a whole bunch
of other questions that we don't even
want to think about so that's that that
when it comes to Joe Biden that pretty
much encompasses everything that he says
it's either you can't understand it at
all
or you can but you wish you couldn't
that's always what it comes down to
I want to read this story to you from
Fox News
I want you to listen to the story
and also
the words that are being used to report
the story by Fox News
Hannah Tubbs formerly known as James
Tubbs discussed a shift in gender
identity as part of a jailhouse phone
call regarding the defense alert
strategy on how the convicted child
molester was being housed prior to a
guilty plea in Los Angeles according to
law enforcement sources with knowledge
of the call
Tubbs is also uh speaking of
indecipherable that I mean it's a it's a
heck of a run-on sentence to start with
but anyway Todds is also an accused
murderer who allegedly began identifying
as female only after being arrested in a
Cold Case child sex assault
investigation in order to get placed
with juvenile girls while awaiting trial
tub 17 at the time of the attack has
criminal records in California Idaho and
Washington and pleaded guilty in the
case last year and involved an assault
on a 10 year old girl in a Denny's
bathroom on New Year's Day in 2014. so
um
so you've probably heard of this this
case this Hannah quote unquote Hannah
Tubbs what's his real name again James
Tubbs so James Tubbs child molester
um convicted Criminal
gets arrested and then discovers his uh
true female identity and this is all a
scheme to get housed with uh with not
just women but underage girls
going back to the fox report
but now Shea Sana the Los Angeles
prosecutor who led the Denny's attack
case has been suspended for five days
without pay for allegedly misgendering
and dead naming tubs by raising concerns
that the repeat offender may have just
been pretending to identify as female to
have an easier situation in lock up as
Fox News digital reported Friday Sana
has argued in the past that jailhouse
phone calls show that tubs now 27 was
attempting to use gender identity to
game the justice system an argument that
sources say made others in gascon's uh
D.A gascon's office uncomfortable and
led to the suspension
however previously undisclosed January
5th 2021 jailhouse phone call recording
uh record phone call recording captured
the first conversation between the newly
minted Hannah tubs and her father
according to law enforcement sources
hey uh Hannah the father says at the
start of the call according to the
sources huh tubs replies Hannah the
father repeats Tubbs replies with a
confused yes according to the sources
and the father explains he had spoken to
defense attorney who called him and said
she represents Hannah I was like who he
replies again with a laugh
okay so there's a jailhouse phone call
where
you could you could tell first of all
that this was uh that based on the
conversation between the father and uh
James Tubb
Tubbs that this was a that this was an
identity that was just invented now the
father's playing along with it
um
in a scheme to get this child molester
housed with with uh with girls
but here's the point
um Fox News article
refers to Hannah Tubbs as a her that's
what the article does on Fox News
now there have actually been a lot of
there's been fox has been on top of this
case and has been reporting it quite a
bit in fact most of what I've heard
about this Hannah tubbed James Tubbs
case has been from Fox News Fox News
um and there are many other examples of
this that I could read but I won't
bother
every single article it's the same deal
they use the her and the she in the
article
now obviously it's insane and evil that
this scumbag Predator pedophile is able
to have his supposed gender identity
respected by the court system
um and the people are getting suspended
for correctly gendering not misgendering
correctly gendering this child molesting
piece of Filth
but also the fact that Fox News an
alleged conservative Outlet
while reporting while reporting on the
fact that the guy is gaming the system
by identifying as trans they're the ones
telling us this
and yet they still respect the female
pronouns
what they're saying is none of this is
real he's pretending I don't know none
of this is real
she is pretending well then why are you
using the she
now I I have an issue in the first place
withdrawing this distinction between men
who are just pretending to identify as
women and men who actually identify as
women that's a distinction without a
difference
because in both cases they're not
actually women
so really the only the only question is
are they consciously lying
or are they
um deeply deeply confused about their
own identity
[Music]
in either case it doesn't change the
reality of the situation
so drawing this distinction between well
that's a pretend trans person and an
actual trans person
there is no such thing as an actual
trans person as in a person who actually
transcends the uh the the the gender
binary or a person who actually you know
uh belongs to one biological category
but somehow is in this other biological
category that doesn't exist there's no
actual there
so I don't agree with the distinction
but it's just very interesting to me
that Fox News they make this distinction
and and even then they still respect the
pronouns
and you find this with uh quite a lot of
so-called con what we call it would
qualifies apparently as conservative or
right-wing media
even reporting a case like this
um
New York Post is another example like it
says a reputation of being right-wing or
conservative which it really isn't
but they report on cases like this all
the time about men who are being housed
with women in uh women's prisons and all
the rest of it still respect the
pronouns
you you are participating in the LIE
and as long if you're going to continue
doing that then the reporting is is
worthless
okay you're exposing the lie but you're
participating in it and uh and affirming
it at the exact same time
which isn't
are you going to be honest in your
reporting or not that's what you have to
decide
let's get to the comment section
[Applause]
who's the blame
it's a sweet baby gang
Rachel says my son just got home from
his day at our local College the first
thing he said was I need to turn on Matt
Walsh to calm down the wokeness of his
Professor was driving him crazy well his
son has a good
head on his shoulder so I think he'll do
okay uh that's a very I'm biased but I
would say that's a very encouraging sign
uh Jack says my wife and I moved about
750 miles last year and we were going to
bring our cats and our baby in a plane
to make the move quicker and easier on
us but I came to the same conclusion as
Matt planes are for people so I found a
way to load the cats up in the back of
my car and I endured the torment of
listening to them howl for 13 hours
rather than making 100 strangers listen
to them for two hours
foreign
I want to give you credit for the
sacrifice that you made but I'm sure you
understand Jack that I I can't do that
because you simply this is you you you
did the right thing
this was your obligation
and I wish that more people would be
willing to do that
and if you're not if you say well it's
not worth it to drive 13 hours for my
pet so then maybe you shouldn't have
pets
okay if you're going to put if if your
convenience is so important I'm not
saying this to you because you
understand this but to everyone else
if your convenience is so important
that um you know for the sake of your
convenience you're going to have to
you're going to expose everyone else to
your pet your animal and make them
listen to the sounds and of your animal
and smell your pet on a plane because
their convenience is that important
it's more important than your pet than
maybe you should be a pet owner
uh Nick says I walked into Lowe's Home
Improvement the other day and a couple
had two large dogs with them they
weren't seeing eye dogs and it was
really annoying I actually had to go out
of my way down an aisle to avoid
tripping over the dog leashes the owner
showed no mind disrespect is what it is
yeah it's also and I've noticed this too
it's like the dogs we already know that
they're brought on planes all the time
but now more and more you know the these
stores big box stores are allowing you
to bring your pet in that's one thing if
we're talking about Petco or something
then it makes sense but a hardware store
why do you gotta bring your pet in
and if it's an actual now there are
people
who have actual disabilities
and so they have service animals and
that's a that's a real thing I respect
that
but I would be even more and if I was
someone who had a disability where I
actually needed a service animal a dog
it's like the only legitimate service
animal
um
I'd be even more annoyed by this
because now I'm getting lumped in I get
all these people abusing the system and
so I'm getting lumped in with them when
I have a legitimate reason to have the
service animal
uh
Gage says I agree with Matt about the
babies crying except for one public
place and that's the movie theaters uh
please do not bring babies to the movies
yeah well the movies there are a number
of places where people should not have
to hear your your baby cry at all now as
I said yesterday I'm much more
um tolerant of listening to babies cry
because that is the price of living in a
human society people have children
families exist this is all a very good
thing it's all very good and so part of
that is you're going to hear the noises
of babies and children and and uh if you
have no tolerance for that whatsoever
that's something wrong there's something
wrong with you and your own soul you
can't even tolerate being around uh
children at all but that is very much
your own problem
we need babies and children to keep
Society going and we can't expect them
to be like totally segregated from
polite Society until they're old enough
where they're not being annoying anymore
especially because plenty of adults are
much more annoying than any child
so that's how I feel but that but there
are certainly places where right you
shouldn't bring a baby and bring a baby
into a movie theater no I would also say
bringing a baby into a nice restaurant
and by nice restaurant I would kind of I
think the cut off is if it's the kind of
restaurant that doesn't have a kid's
menu okay it's the kind of restaurant
where they're not gonna give you a kid's
menu and a little coloring pad with
crayons if it's if it's that kind of
restaurant then yeah bring the kids
bring all the kids it's it's designed
for families and it's designed to be
kind of loud and all that the kind of
restaurant where they would look at you
they would look at you like you're crazy
if you asked for some crayons that kind
of restaurant
probably shouldn't bring babies
finally Charlie says the cuckoo bleep
was hilarious I vote for it staying a
good laugh is welcome when talking about
so many depressing things
I agree I went back and listened to it
and uh it's incredibly stupid but
that's but but I like it
I mean that is hilarious
and gives me more reasons to cuss on the
podcast to cuss like a damned
it was almost a whole year ago that we
released my documentary what is a woman
and it's a a film that we when we were
making it we we knew that it would have
an impact but I have to say that the
impact is far exceeded my own
expectations especially now with um
States all across the country uh passing
laws to protect children from gender
ideology and all this has happened
um you know in in a very short amount of
time so if you have not seen this film
yet you gotta head to dailywire.com
subscribe to become a member and watch
what is a woman today that's
dailywire.com subscribe today now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
for our daily cancellation we turn to
American Idol most interesting thing
about this show is that it is apparently
still on the air
um I don't know if it's indicate if it's
an indication that I'm out of touch or
that American Idol is irrelevant but
until this moment I thought American
Idol was canceled years ago I suppose
that's a false choice however I mean the
answer
could be and probably is both I'm out of
touch and the show is irrelevant be that
as it may um it was back in the cultural
conversation ever so briefly this week
but not for anything related to music or
singing instead it was the story of one
contestant and more specifically a
judge's reaction to that story
that had people talking watch
in May 2018
um a gunman walked into my school
uh
I was in art room one
he shot up art room two
before he made his way to art room one
uh lost a lot of friends
eight students were killed uh two
teachers were killed
and uh it's just really been negative
man stay in the face had a bad rap here
since 2018.
I mean
what you doing Katie I
failed us facts
hey you should be singing here because
you love music
it's true
because you don't have to go through
that
I agree
you don't have to lose eight friends
I hope that you remind people that we
have to change because you know what
it's terrible Katie
it's horrible
[Music]
now before we deal with the substance of
Katy Perry's response to the extent that
it had any substance we cannot ignore
the incredible narcissism on display
here by her
Perry has apparently attended the you
know the same training seminars
alongside Gisele fetterman to learn how
to make other people's traumas about
yourself
he is calmly recounting his own horrific
experience and Perry used it as a
platform to put this they put on this
over-the-top emotional performance
she even relates it back to herself
somehow
I'm scared too she says as her fellow
judges comfort her they start patting
her on the back and comforting her while
the kid who is actually in the shooting
stands there and watches
here's a hint if someone is telling you
about something awful that happened to
them
your response should not contain the
words I or me unless you're saying
something like I'm so sorry or I'm here
for you
but if you're attempting to put yourself
at the center of this person's suffering
or deflect from it so that the focus is
on you and your own emotions
then you are a classic narcissist
and maybe worst of all you're creating
an incredibly awkward situation for
everyone else who has to be in the room
with your lack of self-awareness
I can only imagine how comfortable it
must have been for that young man to be
standing there not sure what to say or
how to respond as Katy Perry launches
into her camera ready monologue like
she's auditioning for a soap opera a
monologue that was planned by the way
considering that the judges would have
known ahead of time that a contestant
was coming up who'd been in a mass
shooting
that fact was certainly conveyed to Katy
Perry and her cohorts by The Producers
before the kid got up on the stage she
didn't she didn't you know burst into
tears spontaneously she had all this
planned in her head ahead of time and I
understand that this is a very cynical
interpretation of events
but I've been around long enough and
I've been in media long enough and I've
met enough of these sorts of people to
justify my cynicism
but what about the actual point she was
making in her scripted diatribe she says
that the country has failed the victims
and survivors of this school shooting
and of course she means specifically
that it failed by not passing enough gun
control laws to prevent the shooting
from happening never mind that the
shooter already broke a dozen different
laws in carrying out his crime it's
unclear how exactly it would have helped
to add one or two more laws onto the
pile that the killer was already
determined to disregard
you could only make and act illegal so
many times before the laws start to
become redundant and therefore useless
yeah this is what we so often do in our
culture when a bad thing happens we
declare that the bad thing is the result
of some sort of failure
it's always a systemic failure failure
of government of policy
people like Katy Perry take solace in
the idea that all tragedies are policy
failures because and really all bad
things you know they say poverty is a
policy failure too
because for one thing it gives them an
excuse to push their political agenda
obviously but for another it Comforts
them to think that the right policies if
we could finally land on them would
banish all the bad things from our midst
when Perry says that the country failed
because there was a school shooting what
she means is that we ought to have a
country where there are no shootings at
all
and she's right in the sense that every
mass shooting and every bad thing
shouldn't happen that's why it's a very
bad thing if there's something that's
evil like any evil shouldn't happen
but Perry like any other leftist
believes that a country without any
murder without any bad people doing bad
things is actually practically
achievable and that it can be achieved
through policy
the irony of course is that the
utopianists who imagined that a world of
perfect peace and Harmony can really be
achieved 10 through their policies to
create a world that is ever farther away
from peace and harmony
worlds like uh the world of Chicago for
example
people people with uh with with Katy
Perry's worldview
run most of our major American cities
and most of our major American cities
are violent crime and disease-ridden
Hell holes which actually isn't all that
ironic when you realize that effective
governance means understanding human
nature and understanding human nature
means acknowledging that bad people will
always exist and they will always do bad
things you can do a lot uh you can do a
much better job of containing and
mitigating the damage
but you can only do that once you've
acknowledged the Fallen state of man and
that although you can mitigate the
damage and try to contain it
there will always be damage to mitigate
and contain
with all that said
it's still true that a school shooting
represents a failure in fact it's a
whole series of failures
but they're mostly the kinds of failures
that Katy Perry and her ilk never want
to talk about
first of all it's a moral failure of the
person who carries out the deed people
have agency they have free will they
choose to do things
they should be the first people we blame
for the things that they choose to do
rather than pinning it on the country
um
and also very often there have been
parenting failures that help to produce
the sorts of people who would do
something like that
and failures in a culture which breeds
people who have no meaning no purpose in
their lives seemingly no capacity for
empathy or or love
these are all failures
and they're the kinds of failures we
skip over focusing instead on debates
over gun control
and that itself is also a failure
one which only ensures that this kind of
thing will keep happening with the same
or greater frequency
and that is why Katy Perry is today
finally canceled
and I'll do it for the show today hope
you have a great day we'll talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
today on the Ben Shapiro show mayor Lori
Lightfoot doesn't even make it past the
first round of voting in Chicago a St
Louis man shoots a homeless man point
blank on the street we examine the
reasons why and the Supreme Court
considers striking down Joe Biden's
student loan bailout as Democrats whine
that's today on the Ben Shapiro show
give it a listen